Right.
Do I want to know?
I want to know the whole thing.
I want to know as far into this as you can tell me why you think this,
right.
Like instead of me just saying no,
you're wrong.
I wanna I want you to explain it to me.
I want to know whether or not I trust your process.
Do you bring that skill home with you?
I mean,
you're surrounded by women.
It's tough.
It's tough,
bro.
I,
I'm serious,
like said times cause I even see it with my own husband.
We have three daughters.
But I mean,
especially,
you know,
when you have a pretty masculine male,
I'm always fascinated to watch them navigate their home when they're surrounded
by women.
I just give up.
Most of the time I lose every argument.
Um,
I think,
um,
you know,
I tried to,
we communicate a lot,
loved talking,
a lot of failing with girls.
It's always those things they're crying about and like,
okay,
we're going to be fine.
And you know,
I don't want them to be like me.
I want them to be themselves and I want him to be girls.
I want it to be able to be themselves.
I don't want them to mirror my resilience,
you know,
I want them to be vulnerable if they want to be vulnerable.
But it's a,
in terms of like how I decorate the house or,
oh,
I have no say,
oh no.
Nothing.
You know,
that's why you have,
you know,
I have this place I was going to say,
you have your,
your cave here at Laird has a barn.
Perfect.
And He,
you know,
when he meets young guys getting married,
he goes,
here,
I'm going to teach you.
Okay,
you're right honey.
I'm sorry.
And Oh yes.
Whatever color you choose,
you know,
always work.
Some people it's never enough,
but if you have the right relationships,
sometimes it'll work that way.
Cause I don't give a fuck what my house looks like.
I really don't know.
I have a good view.
Where's the coffee?
Yeah.
Okay.
It's like real work.
Yeah.
Okay.
How's the bed?
That's a good bed.
Do we have a TV?
Where's the TV?
Is it a good one?
That's a good TV.
All right.
We're good.
I have a laptop.
Okay.
We're good.
Yeah.
I don't need that much.
You know,
so like when my wife was like,
I'm going to put this here,
I'm like,
okay,
put it there.
Fantastic.
I want to get that painting.
Okay.
Get the painting.
I don't know.
I don't know where you want to put it.
Yeah,
put it where it feels right.
I don't give a fuck.
I think it's smart.
I mean,
you know,
like sometimes if I am fringe on,
if it's functional,
then layered steps in like w you know,
that's not really functional.
But otherwise he's like,
I'm tearing some stuff out of my house right now and he just gives me a look and
I'm like,
I'm this age if I want to do this,
support me.
And he just laughs and walks out.
Like he just probably doesn't care.
Go ahead.
Just,
just,
it's in the way,
whatever it is,
whatever.
Have Fun with it.
Yeah.
What Time's dinner?
You know,
love to decorate things.
I get nervous if a guy's really into it.
Well,
yeah,
it's a nesting trek guys are like really into like the design in,
in their own house.
Like really,
really into it.
Like constantly obsessing about where things are and where they're supposed to
be policed.
Homosexuals.
Yeah.
I can't play out there.
What do you mean?
Is that a stereotypical thing that is outrageous?
That might be,
he might've showed your whites or privacy.
I'm not exactly sure.
Yeah.
It's a funny thing.
Right.
But,
uh,
if I didn't have this place though,
I don't know if I,
like traditionally men had pool halls they can hang out at,
or gyms that they would hang out in and they would get their dose of toxic
masculinity.
Yeah.
Her basement or a basement.
You can create a place where nobody's touching your stuff.
Yeah.
Well,
if you live in a house,
like I do with all girls too.
It's,
it's just everything's girly.
I just,
whatever.
I'm fine.
Laird said he,
he's like,
I need it to be more specific.
I said I wanted to be surrounded by women.
I was like,
I didn't mean to be related to all of them.
That's hilarious.
You know,
it's,
I think it's a nature or God's way of balancing off.
They say if guys have elevated body temperature,
so athletes,
people who train a lot,
that they're statistically have a greater chance of having daughters because I
think they hot,
we call it hot balls basically,
if he kills off the male sperm.
That's hilarious.
And if you look around,
I think so they did a thing on a,
a bunch of guys,
either in the NFL or whatever,
and statistically they just have a lot more daughters.
And I think it's like nature's way of going,
oh,
you're going to be all like moving and active and raw and all this stuff.
Guess what?
We're just gonna put a bunch of girls around you and for you,
because my daughter say things to my husband,
I could never say as a wife,
you know,
it's like I see it and I just go,
oh yeah,
well they know that for sure.
He loves them so they can get away with it.
They're in.
Yeah.
They can't get fired.
No,
I always say that to them.
Like my youngest daughter when she was really little,
like five or six,
she'd say,
okay,
so I'm not really clear with this.
Um,
when I have alone time I'm by myself.
And when you and dad need alone time,
like you're together.
And I try to like,
well you know,
it's important for moms and dads cause you know,
we have to work at it.
I go,
you know,
you're,
you're always going to be dad's daughter.
I,
you know,
I'm,
we're working at being a husband and wife and then she'd keep going with it.
And I finally would just say like,
Hey,
do you want to have Christmas in separate houses?
And I'd see her think for a second like,
well maybe,
you know,
and I'm like,
we need a long time.
I took it to present.
That's what I told that she's processing that.
She's like,
well I'd miss you,
but I don't know.
You know,
so it's all that dance,
you know,
cause daughters,
man,
they don't miss a trick and they're on you and they're on their dad like
nobody's business.
While my friends would have sons,
the way they say it is,
it's like you can take one of two things.
Either you have this wild animal that's tearing things apart or you have someone
who's screaming and crying about something you don't understand.
Yeah.
Take your pick.
You went to judo?
Yeah,
a mental destroyer or a physical destroyer.
Yeah.
Walls with holes and broken.
Broken bones
and girls.
It's like I have learned so much being a mother,
two daughters,
and I've been around women my whole life.
You figure playing volleyball and being tons of women.
It's very different as a parent.
I mean I've learned the most,
especially teenagers.
Watching them grow so strange.
It's such a strange experience watching a person figure out the world from,
from jump,
you know,
like out the womb,
figure out the world.
It's so educational.
I feel.
I don't think everyone should have children.
I'm not one of those zealots that tells everybody,
Hey,
you're not alive until you have a kid.
No,
I think it's unfair to say that to people.
That is unfair.
I think it's,
first of all,
a lot of people can't write and maybe they have a just a different path.
Like I always tell my girlfriends too,
like it's unfair also to romanticize like to your friends who either opted not
to have children or whatever,
met a partner too late or didn't or whatever because I think it is a really
rich,
I mean there's nothing like it.
I mean I love my children,
but if I had one friend,
she was like got married later and she was like,
you know,
we're going to adopt.
And um,
she was also doing a new business and I was like,
listen,
I need to come.
I want to talk to you.
And she also like to consider taking naps occasionally.
I was like,
if you think you're going to adopt and like,
you're going to have a 12 year old that's like a,
hey,
I really appreciate you guys.
Thank you so much.
I go,
that's not what you know.
Like if you think you're going to have a kid and it's gonna make you happier,
that's not what having a kid is.
I think it makes you,
it makes you know yourself better in a different way and you can adapt and do
something different.
But I,
I think when people sort of sell that bill of goods,
like,
Oh,
you've got to have kids.
It's like,
well,
do you want to have kids?
You know,
I think it's like you said,
not for everyone.
You definitely shouldn't adopt.
You think it's going to be easy.
That's what I mean.
It's like she had this romantic idea of like,
and I go,
you know,
you don't,
first of all,
you don't know what the,
what's where the kid is coming from.
And then also you have a romance.
I think every parent going into it has a romantic idea.
I did.
And I'm a pretty realistic person of like,
I'm going to do all these things right and we're gonna be,
you know,
running in sunflower fields together and my kids are never going to think my
music sucks,
or I can drive.
And then you realize,
I had a friend tell me,
everyone gets their turn in the barrel.
No matter what you do.
Uh,
you got,
you have to navigate stuff,
you're going to have to deal with stuff for sure.
And on the other hand,
it's awesome when someone does adopt people,
if they're really into it,
if they know what they're getting into and those martyrs out there and those
people that are just super kind and generous and love to adopt children of God
bless them.
Yeah.
So glad they're there.
It's just,
I agree with you that there are some people that have a romanticized idea of
what it's like to raise a child and it's unfair to,
to sell it.
Like I love the moms.
What?
So when are you going to have number two or whatever to somebody it's like,
oh,
you know that they're behind closed doors doing,
you know,
like they just want everyone to be in the psychotic ness with them.
I have three kids.
You should have three kids.
You know,
there are people like that,
right?
Yeah.
There's people that have a kid then immediately take this moral high ground,
looks like they're doing something during an adult and you're,
you're just a fool.
Yeah.
You're like,
I wonder who is the fool?
It's like I ask myself that sometimes.
Well,
don't you think you're a better person for raising kids?
Do,
does it make you feel like you're more in tune and nicer and just more aware of
what it is,
what it means to be a human?
Yeah.
I,
I not only that I,
I feel like,
I feel like it's,
it's a forced expiration if you're trying to participate.
Like if you just lay down the law and go,
hey,
in this house,
this is how we do it,
then you're not doing anything.
But I think if you,
you learn to adapt and also go,
wow,
I was doing that wrong for like 10 years.
Amazing.
You know?
Like I've,
one of my daughters at a 12 or 13 sort of revealed some stuff about what she was
unhappy about,
about my parenting and I was like,
God,
I've been doing that for a long time.
Uh,
so I think it's,
it's cool that she had the confidence to do that though.
Yeah.
It's so cool.
I wanted to hear that.
Like when she was 30 at the Thanksgiving table when she moved out,
I was like,
what?
You're supposed to reveal all that?
Like after you move out.
And then I go,
oh,
what did I do that,
sorry.
Turned out great.
It's amazing.
What time's your flight?
Uh,
no,
no.
Listen,
it's a,
it's a surrender.
I think for me it's,
it's been a real surrender because I,
I just think I,
you think you're in control of stuff and you think,
oh,
I've got some discipline and work ethic.
I can just work my way through it or power my way through it.
And then you realize like,
no,
you have to surrender.
And,
and also it's not just about solving it quickly and,
um,
yeah,
it is.
I'm,
I know myself certainly better,
but also it forces you if you're willing to,
to really expand.
Yeah.